Hallo, guten Tag, ich heiße Aydin. Ich möchte mit Ihnen das an der Neske
sprechen. Zuerst brauche ich Ihre persönlichen Daten, persönliche Daten.
Dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Hallo, guten Abend. Guten Tag. Wie heißen Sie? Mein Name ist Christine Müller.
Christine Müller. Könnten Sie Ihre Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam stabilieren?
Ja, natürlich. Christine wie Christine. Es ist Cesar Heinrich, Richard, Ida, S wie Siegfried,
T wie Theodor, I wie Ida, N wie Nordpol und E wie Emil. Christine, Müller, Marta,
U wie U, L, L, E, Richard, Müller. Frau Müller, sind Sie Frau? Ja, Sie sehen doch, Christine
ist eine Frau natürlich. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren? Ich bin 64 Jahre alt.
Am 23.04.1964. Okay. Könnten Sie Ihre Datumtag wiederholen?
23.04.1962. 30.04. April. Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie? Ich wiege ca. 65 Kilo.
Ich bin etwas kleiner geworden, glaube ich. Aber 1,58 Meter. Frau Müller, was haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen heute helfen? Herr Doktor, was soll ich dazu sagen? Also das geht schon
seit drei Wochen und ist nicht besser geworden und jetzt seit einer Woche sogar noch schlimmer.
Ich habe Kopfschmerzen und das ist auf der linken Seite unter dem Auge über der Wange
und zum einen ich bekomme keine Luft über der linken Seite der Nase und dann habe ich so
starken Druck auf dem Auge und es strahlt weiter nach oben zum Kopf bis nach hinten zum Rücken.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer numerischen Schale von 0 bis 10?
0 kein Schmerzen, 10 sehr stark Schmerzen. Also jetzt seit einer Woche schon sehr stark.
Ich würde sagen so zwischen 5 und 7. Jetzt könnten Sie wie viel sagen?
7. Haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen? Die ganze Zeit schon. Ich habe zuerst mit
Paracetamol probiert, dann habe ich Ibuprofen genommen und jetzt habe ich noch zusätzlich
Novalgine, aber so richtig besser wird es nicht. Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen aushalten
oder soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben? Jetzt geht es im Moment, aber es wird sicherlich
schlimmer werden jetzt in den nächsten ein, zwei Stunden, deswegen bin ich gekommen. Ich
gebe Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel und wenn es eine Besserung gibt, füllen Sie sich eine kleine
Besserung und wir weitermachen. Was wollen Sie mir geben? Ich habe schon vor einer Stunde
Novalgine genommen. Ja okay, verzeihen Sie. Manchmal andere Medikament Schmerzmittel geben Sie.
Ist bei Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverzirklichkeit bekannt? Nein, alleine habe ich nichts. Okay,
manchmal eine starke Schmerzmittel geben Sie. Oh, da wäre ich sehr dankbar, ja. Vielen,
danke. Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben? Siehendruckend oder dunf, Polykartik?
Also wie ich schon sagte, es ist eher so ein drückender Schmerz und es strahlt aus,
von über das Auge bis zum Kopf. Ja, haben Sie gesagt. Und ich bekomme auf die
linken Seite der Nase keine Luft und ich habe das Gefühl, dass das jetzt seit einer Woche
auch etwas schwillt. Das ist ein bisschen das Gesicht und die Wange unter dem Auge,
dass da, wenn ich mich im Spiegel angucke, dass da ein Unterschied ist. Okay, es gibt
eine unterschiedliche Vergrosserung, meinst du? Ja, eine Schwellung, ja. Ja, Schwellung. Okay.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen immer da oder wiederkehrend? Also seit einer Woche sind sie dauerhaft,
ja. Dauerhaft, aber früher nicht dauerhaft. Genau, da war es immer nur kurzfristig
kommend und gehend, aber jetzt ist es dauerhaft, ja. Okay, sind Ihre Schmerzen zum
ersten Mal langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten? Langsam. Langsam. Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser
für Ihre Schmerzen? Ich weiß es nicht, es hat langsam angefangen und ich dachte,
das ist noch eine leichte Erkältung, aber es ist immer schlimmer geworden. Okay, gibt es
etwas, was Ihre Schmerzen lindert oder versteckt? Kann ich nicht sagen, also wie gesagt,
am Anfang war es nicht so schlimm, aber jetzt seit einer Woche ist es schlimm. Ja, ja. Aber
Novalgin oder Ibuprofen nicht besser geworden. Immer nur ganz kurz,
finde ich schon leichter und dann geht es wieder los. Haben Sie eine linderte Faktoren
bemerkt? Nein. Okay. Nija Atage haben Sie oder Schubartike? Was für nichts haben Sie gesagt?
Schubartike. Schubartike? Ja. Ihre Schmerzen, sind Ihre Schmerzen schubartike oder nicht?
Ach so, nein, wie gesagt, am Anfang waren sie immer wieder, mehr oder mal weniger,
aber jetzt sind sie dauerhaft, nicht schubartig, dauerhaft. Okay. Haben Sie
eine Beschwerden früher? Also ich habe schon seit vielen Jahren so ein Problem mit
Nase. Haben Sie Nasenbeschwerden? Okay. Und da hat auch der Halsnase- und Ohrenarzt gemeint,
ich muss operiert werden, aber ich habe bisher keine Operation. Ich wollte auch keine Operation.
Okay. Würden Sie damals eine Diagnose festgestellt? Die meinten, ich habe Polypen
auf der linken Seite, aber ich wollte erstmal keine OP, ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor
Operationen gehabt. Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Nachschweiß? Bisher noch
nicht, aber starke Kopfschmerzen. Was? Weil das Gefühl, dass mein linkes Auge auch sehr stark
drückt und schmerzhaft ist. Ja, ja, haben Sie gesagt. Ist Ihnen schwindlig oder
ohnmächtig? Schwindlig ist mir es noch nicht, ohnmächtig bin ich auch noch nicht geworden.
Ist Ihnen Atem-, Luftnot- oder Hüsten-, Herzrasen-, Herzklopfen aufgefallen? Nein.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen? Nein. Schlafen Sie gut? Jetzt wegen den Kopfschmerzen
eigentlich nicht, nein. Seit einer Woche oder seit drei Wochen? Einer Woche eigentlich,
mehr eine Woche. Davor war es auch etwas eingeschränkt mit dem Schlafen. Es ging,
aber jetzt seit einer Woche ganz schlecht. Okay. Waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden beim
Hausarzt? Ja, ich war schon beim Hausarzt, ja. Was würde Sie Diagnose festgestellt oder was
hat er gemacht? Was er gemacht hat? Er meinte, das ist ein Virusinfekt, hat mir nur Schleimlöser
gegeben und Nasenspray und meinte, das geht wieder vorbei. Okay. Aber gibt es keine
Besserung? Nein, sonst wäre ich ja nicht hier bei Ihnen. Ja, ja, ich verstehe. Haben Sie
in letzter Zeit ein Gewicht verloren oder so genommen? Nein. Ist Ihnen Schwierigkeit beim
Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang aufgefallen? Nein, bisher noch nicht. Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ganz gut, aber jetzt in letzter Zeit eher weniger. Wahrscheinlich jetzt wegen
dem Infekt, denke ich, aber normalerweise ganz gut. Ja, gibt es eine Hautveränderung oder
Verletzung? Bei mir meinen Sie jetzt oder? Ja. Wo? Am Gesicht? Im Gesicht ja auch. Haben Sie gesagt,
eine Schwellung, aber haben Sie eine Rotung oder eine Gesichtveränderung, Hautveränderung
oder Verletzung? Sie waren jetzt am Gesicht. Jaja oder egal. Sie können sich selbst angucken.
Ja, manchmal. Ich habe jetzt nichts bemerkt, nein. Okay. Ist Ihnen vor der Schmerzen
oder nicht? Leiden Sie unter einer chronischen Erkrankung? Was meinen Sie mit chronischer
Erkrankung? Eine Erkrankung. Würden Sie früher eine Erkrankung festgestellt?
Ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck seit einigen Jahren und nehme wegen auch Medikamente.
Ja. Und ich habe einen Knoten der Schilddrüse und da habe ich Medikamente gegen die Schilddrüse.
Okay. Haben Sie sonst? Sonst? Nein, an sich nicht, nein. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich bin am linken Eierstock mal operiert worden. Da war eine Zyste. Wann? Ohje,
das ist schon fast 25 Jahre her. 22? 25 Jahre. Vor 25 Jahren. Ja, okay. Seit wann haben Sie
Bluthochdruck und Knoten Schilddrüse? Schilddrüse Knoten? Die Schilddrüse Knoten geht schon länger,
da war ich schon glaube ich 30. Das hat man im Ultraschall gesehen. Okay. Und der Doktor meinte,
ich müsste auch Medikamente nehmen. Das wird immer regelmäßig kontrolliert. Ja. Und was
war nochmal die zweite Frage bitte? Bluthochdruck. Haben Sie ein paar Jahre gesagt? Also ja. Was
meinten Sie? Ja, so circa sechs Jahre sind das, wenn ich Tabletten nehme. Ich hatte vorher auch
schon. Welche Tablette? Welche Tablette? Oh, da muss ich nochmal nachschauen. Ich glaube,
irgendwas mit Kandesartan. Ah, genau Herr Doktor. Das war eine Abends. Erinnern Sie sich,
welche Dosierung? Oh Gott, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Müssen Sie zu Hause nochmal nachschauen,
weiß ich nicht. Okay, vielen Dank. Nehmen Sie so seit irgendwelche Medikamente außer Kandesartan
und auch Paracetamol, Ibuprofen und Novalgine? Nein, nein. Novalgine nicht. Okay. Nehmen Sie
für Schildrose ein Medikament ein? Ja, genau. Das sind L-Tiroxin und das sind 50 Milligramm,
glaube ich, drauf. Okay, einmal täglich oder? Ja, Schildrose-Tablette einmal. Morgen. Ist
bei Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt? Haben Sie gesagt nein, aber? Also
Unverträglichkeit jetzt an sich nicht, aber Allergien habe ich. Also ich habe eine
Penicillin-Allergie, ich habe eine Pollen-Allergie, ich habe jetzt den Namen vergessen,
aber auch Allergien gegen, sagen Sie schon, Vitamin C. Vitamin C. Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Auch? Gegen Penicillin, Pollen und Vitamin C? Also Pollen, da läuft bei mir immer die Nase
oder die Augen brennen und ich kriege immer für 3-4 Monate ganz schlecht Luft. Das ist
die Pollen-Allergie und was habe ich noch gesagt? Penicillin und Vitamin C. Die Antibiotika,
da habe ich mal als junge Frau Penicillin bekommen, hatte ganz Körper-Autschlag und
musste auch ins Krankenhaus und Vitamin C, da habe ich mir mal vor einigen Jahren mal
Infusionen geben lassen und da habe ich plötzlich auch schlecht Luft bekommen,
Herzasen und hatte so einen Ausschlag. Ja, ok. Hat gemeint, das ist wahrscheinlich Vitamin C.
Ok, ich habe alle notiert. Rauchen Sie Frau Müller? Seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr, nein. Ok,
früher haben Sie geraucht? Da habe ich geraucht, ja. Wie viele Mal täglich? Ich muss mal schauen.
Wie viele Zigaretten täglich? Ja, es gab Phasen, da habe ich fast eine Schachtel am Tag geraucht,
aber meistens war es immer nur eine halbe Schachtel. Ok. Seit wie vielen Jahren haben
Sie geraucht? Also wie viele Jahre insgesamt, meinen Sie? Ja. Es war fast 25 Jahre. 25 Jahre? Ja. Ok,
trinken Sie Alkohol? Ja, selten. Was meinen Sie, einmal pro Woche, einmal pro Monat?
Noch weniger. Wenn ich mal auf einem Geburtstagsfeier bin oder auf einem Fest,
dann. Ok, manchmal Wein oder Bier? Eher Wein. Ok. Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen oder
konsumieren Sie Drogen? Nein, nein. Ok, perfekt. Treiben Sie Sport? Eigentlich sollte ich,
aber an sich nicht, nein. Ok, gibt es in Ihrer Familie eine chronische Erkrankung? Was meinen Sie
Familie? Also. Ja, Arteriehypert, Bluthochdruck, Blutzuckerkrankheit oder Myokardinfarktus,
Apoplex, Schlaganfall. Also meine Eltern sind ja schon verstorben. Es tut mir leid. Meine Mutter,
das weiß ich noch, hatte mal Diabetes, aber ich glaube, die hat nur Tabletten bekommen. Ok. Und
mein Vater ist leider jetzt auch vor drei Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben. Herzinfarkt. Erinnern Sie
sich, darf ich fragen, im welchem Alter ist Ihr Vater gestorben? Er war, wie alt war er,
so circa 83 Jahre alt. 83 Jahre. Und auch Ihre Mutter? Sie war 79. 79. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe nur eine Schwester. Ok, ist sie gesund? Ja, sie ist fitter als ich. Sie ist auch ein paar
jünger als ich. Und soweit ich weiß, hat sie auch jetzt keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Perfekt. Frau Müller, wie ist Ihr Familienstand? Sind Sie verheiratet, oder?
Ich war verheiratet, dann bin ich geschieden. Schon seit vier Jahren, ich lebe alleine.
Ok, vier Jahre allein. Haben Sie Kinder? Ich habe einen Sohn, ja. Ist er gesund?
Ja, ja, soweit ich weiß, ja. Also bisher nicht. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rentnerin, jetzt seit kurzem. Und ich habe in einer Firma gearbeitet als Bauleitung.
Bauleitung. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Frau Müller? Also mein Haus meinte, ich habe alle
Impfungen, ja. Perfekt. Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland? Nein, aber das habe ich vor.
Ich möchte jetzt in den nächsten Jahren so ein bisschen die Welt bereisen, aber gerne,
dass hier mal jetzt geklärt wird. Ok. Frau Müller, letzte Fragen. Ich frage Sie,
sind Sie jetzt im Wechseljahr? Oh, seit über 15 Jahren schon. Haben Sie Beschwerden bei,
oder sind Sie regelmäßig bei Frauenarztinnen besuchen? Haben Sie Besuchen?
Glücklicherweise habe ich bisher jetzt nichts, aber alle zwei Jahre gehe ich mal hin, ja. Ok,
perfekt. Frau Müller, ich habe alle wichtige gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen,
oder haben Sie an mich Fragen? Nein, vielen Dank. Also das war ja sehr ausführlich. Ich würde
gerne wissen, was das ist, was man dann noch machen kann. Jetzt habe ich schon Nasenspray,
Schmerz-Tabletten, und es wird immer noch nicht besser. Langsam mache ich mir Sorgen,
und deswegen bin ich hier. Ich verstehe Sie, Frau Müller. Sie haben einen Kopfschmerzen,
aber es ist so früh etwas zu sagen. Wir brauchen erst körperliche Untersuchungen,
dann Blut abnehmen und auch danach ein paar bildgebende Untersuchungen durchführen. Jetzt,
wie werden Sie körperlich untersuchen? Könnten Sie auf die Liga legen?
Ok, das geht ja schnell jetzt. Vielen Dank. Haben Kollegen oder
Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen? Ja, darf ich eine Frage? Bitte schön.
Frau Müller, können Sie mir sagen, mit der Beschränzung eine Behöfungsempfindlichkeit
auf der betroffenen Seite? Ich habe sie leider ganz schlecht verstanden.
Beschränzung eine Behöfungsempfindlichkeit auf der betroffenen Seite. Ja, ja, ich habe
gesagt, es tut weh, es ist geschwollen, und wenn man das anfasst, dann tut es auch weh.
Eine Lichtempfindlichkeit auch? Lichtempfindlichkeit?
Lichtempfindlichkeit ist mir noch nicht so aufgefallen, aber wenn viel Licht ist,
dann stört mich das. Das stimmt ja. Ok, danke schön.
Ok, sind noch Fragen? Wer will was reden?
Die linke Seite, Schmerzen, Palais de Paris hat gefragt.
Ah, ich habe nichts gefragt. Frau Müller, würden Sie bei Ihnen eine Diagnose
genannt, während der Infektionperiode, wenn Sie beim Haushalt gewesen?
Der hat schon mal gesagt, das ist ein Virusinfekt, mehr weiß er nicht.
Vielleicht wäre es eine Herpesinfektion, hätten Sie eine ähnliche Diagnose genannt?
Nein, das habe ich vorher nicht gehabt. Hätten Sie während einer offenen Wunde
eine kleine Bühne im Gesicht? Ach so, offene Wunde im Gesicht habe ich nicht, nein.
Es gibt eine Nase am Polisgeschichte und linksseitige.
Ja. Jetzt haben Sie sehr stark oder während
dieser zwei Wochenperiode, hätten Sie sehr starke Probleme?
So wie gesagt erst seit einer Woche, aber ich denke, das hängt mit den Kopfschmerzen
zusammen. Das ist meine Ermutung, ich weiß es nicht. Aber den auf der linken Seite ist,
ich meine, ein bisschen schlechter. Okay, könnten wir Arsatske-Shibri anfangen,
Hr. Okay. Bitte schon, Hr. Arzt. Ja, hallo, Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen
Patienten. Ich möchte Ihnen die Patient vorstellen. Haben Sie Zeit dafür?
Aber natürlich. Vielen Dank. Bitte schön, erzähl mal, was hast du dir angeschaut?
Ja, ich habe die 64-jährige Patientin, Frau Christine Müller, ist 65 Kilogramm,
1,8 Kilogramm schwer, 1,58 Meter groß. Die Patientin stellte sich heute wegen seit
drei Wochen bestehender, langsam aufgetretener, druckender linkerseitiger Cephalgie mit
Australen von Nasen bis Nacken oder bis Hinterhaupt. Hinterhaupt oder Hinterkopf?
Hinterkopf. Die Patientin berichtet, dass die Schmerzen auf einer nummerischen Skala
bei 5 bis 7 von 10 seien und die Schmerzen hätten sich im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert,
besonders letzte Woche. Die Patientin klagt über Schwellungegesichts und eine linkseitige
Cephalgie. Hast du noch andere neurologische Symptome? Augendruckend, augedruckend.
Sie hat ja auch eine Sehverschlechterung oder eine Seheinschränkung. Ich habe
nicht gefragt. Die Patientin hat es gesagt, du hast auch gefragt. Ja, aber ich, ah,
Patientin hat gesagt, aber es gibt eine augendruckende Augen gesagt.
Nicht drückende Augen, sondern sie hat einen Druck auf den Augen.
Ha, Druck auf den Augen. Und dadurch auch ein bisschen eine
eingeschränkte Sicht oder Sehfähigkeit.
Und es gibt eine Nasenpolypen-Geschichte, aber sie sei nicht operiert worden.
Eine Nasenpolypen-Vorgeschichte.
Ja, Nasenpolypen-Vorgeschichte und sie sei nicht operiert worden. Die
Vegetative-Anamnese ist bis auf Insomnie und Inappetenz unauffällig.
Sie leidet an arterielle Hypertonie seit sechs Jahren, eine Stroma seit 30 Jahren und sie
sei wegen einer linkseitigen Hodensüste operiert worden.
Was war eine Süste?
Verzeihen, Overyal-Süste.
Eine Hodensüste ist ein bisschen...
Verzeihen, ich habe hergedacht. Overyal-Süste.
Vor 25 Jahren operiert worden und sie nehmen zurzeit...
Wie heißt es?
Candesartan.
Candesartan, ja. Candesartan.
Okay, welche Dosierung hat sie?
Ja, die Patientin hat nicht erinnert, versagen sie.
Ah, sie wusste die Dosierung nicht, okay.
Meine...
Dürfen.
Ja, die Patientin nimmt zurzeit Candesartan.
Candesartan, genau, das ist die Gruppe der Sartaner.
Ja, Candesartan.
Zweimal täglich L-Tiroxin, 50 Milligramm.
Einmal und gegen Kopfschmerzen.
Nicht so schnell.
Sie nimmt L-Tiroxin, 50 Milligramm, haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Nicht Milligramm, Mikrogramm, ich glaube.
Genau, bei den Schilddrüsen ist es die Mikrogramm, richtig?
Ja, Mikrogramm.
Einmal und gegen Kopfschmerzen Paracetamol, Ibuprofen und Novalgine eingenommen.
Aber ich habe vor drei Stunden eine Novalgine letztes Mal eingenommen.
Und...
Reicht es gegen die Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, es...
Es hat eine kleine Verbesserung gebracht.
Ah, ok.
Eine kleine Verbesserung gebracht.
Und sie reagiert auf Penicillin mit Anaphylaktischok,
auf Vitamin C, auf Vitamin C, auch mit Anaphylaktischok und Pollen,
eine laufende Nase und...
Sekretierung.
Laufende Nase und...
Nochmal zu der Frage, Sie meinen Anaphylaktischok, war Sie nicht?
Ja, ich habe gesagt.
Diese Allergie auf Penicillin, war das nur ein Hautausschlag?
Hautausschlag?
Aber haben Sie gesagt, wegen dieser...
Ja.
Der Patient hat gesagt, nach dem Hautausschlag,
er bekam keine Luft.
Ja.
Exanthem.
Ein Exanthem, ok.
Eine Anaphylaktische Schock ist ja schon etwas mehr, oder?
Ja, ja.
Auch Patienten mit Luftproblemen und auch anderen Problemen zu leben.
Was heißt andere Probleme?
Ja, ich meine, eine Luftschmerzen.
Also Sie hat Dyspnoe?
Ja, Dyspnoe.
Sie hat Dyspnoe bekommen, Sie hat ein allergisches Exanthem.
Aber schockig war Sie jetzt nicht?
Für Vitamine sehr auch, aber...
Ok, ok.
Aber das ist kein anaphylaktischer Schock.
Das ist vielleicht ein allergisches Exanthem.
Ja, gegen Penicillin richtig, ja.
Ok, alles klar. Gut.
Machen wir weiter. Was haben Sie noch für Informationen?
Ja, die Patienten seit 10 Jahren nicht sauber.
Aber früher ein Schachtel, halbes Schachtel bis ein Schachtel,
es war seit 25 Jahren geraucht.
Wie viele Packen sind es dann?
Ja, etwa 25 Packungen hier.
Ok.
Und sie trinken so selten am Fest oder an der Geburtstag.
Was trinkt sie? Wasser oder was?
Wein.
Sie trinken Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol. Ich meine Alkohol.
Ach so, ok. Sie haben nichts getan.
Nichts.
Was Sie meinen?
Die Fragen nach Drogenkonsum und Sporttreiben wurden verneint.
Ok.
Der Vater ist an einem Myokardinfarkt im Alter von 83 Jahren gestorben.
Die Mutter sei Diabetes mellitus type 2 im Alter von 79 Jahren gestorben.
Sie haben eine Geschwister.
Darf ich kurz intervenieren? Die Mutter sei Diabetes type 2.
Ja.
Kein richtiger Satz. Die Mutter...
An. Sei an Diabetes mellitus type 2.
Sie ist type 2 erkrankt.
Aber wenn sie verstorben ist, dann heißt das, die Mutter hatte Diabetes 2.
Und ist... Verstorben haben Sie gesagt, gell?
Ja.
Wann ist sie verstorben? Wie lang ist das hier?
Oder wie alt war die Mutter?
Im Alter von 79 Jahren.
Ok. Und was heißt das? Woran ist sie verstorben?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ok. Alles klar.
Also das heißt, dann müssen Sie sagen, die Mutter ist vor wie viel?
3 Jahren, 2 Jahren verstorben.
Und sie hatte aber Diabetes. Noch was anderes?
Die Mutter, es gibt keine mehr. Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Nicht gefragt. Ok.
Weil...
Ja.
Ich habe nicht vorhin gefragt.
Aber bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Ich frage nach.
Frage ich nach.
Alles klar. Gut. Weiter.
Ja.
Sie sei...
...geschieden vor 4 Jahren.
Und lebe allein.
Habe eine gesunde Kinder.
Sie sei...
Stopp, stopp, stopp.
Sie sind zu schnell, lieber HTP.
Sie machen viele grammatikalische Fehler.
Und das kann Ihnen zu einem Problem werden.
Sie habe einen Sohn.
Eine gesunde Sohn, ja.
Sie sei...
Sie habe eine Kinder.
Das war als ein und Kinder.
Also Singular, Plural.
Das ist nicht ganz korrekt.
Sie habe ein Kind oder Sie habe einen Sohn.
Einen Sohn, ja richtig.
Einen gesunden Sohn.
Und sie sei Rentnerin.
Und...
...habe...
Sie habe früher...
...als eine...
...in einer Firma...
...von Bauleiterin...
Sie sei...
Sie...
Sie habe...
...als Bauleiter...
...in der eine Firma...
...gearbeitet.
Die schöne deutsche liebe Grammatik, ja?
Ja, ja.
Sehr gut.
Gut. War das das oder haben Sie noch mehr Informationen?
Ja, die Fragen nach...
...oder...
...der Impfstatus...
...ist vollständig.
Und...
...ja, die Fragen nach...
...Auslandreise und Frauenamnese...
...wurden verneint.
Und was für eine Anamnese?
Frauenamnese.
Frauenamnese?
Ja, Frauenamnese wurden verneint.
Was ist eine Frauenamnese?
In Wechseljahre...
...und es gibt keine besondere Situation.
Ach, das meint Sie mit Frauenamnese.
Okay.
Okay, alles klar. Gut.
Ist unauffällig.
Mit Frauenamnese habe ich jetzt nicht gekannt.
Ja.
Dann würde ich sagen, die...
...genau, gynaecologische Anamnese...
...oder die gynaecologischen Erkrankungen haben Sie nicht.
Oder Sie haben keine Symptome...
...meine Pause.
Okay.
Die Frauenamnese ist unauffällig.
Genau. Wenn, dann sagen Sie lieber gynaecologische Anamnese.
Gynaecologische Anamnese, okay.
Sie sprechen jetzt mit einem Oberarzt...
...und dann sollten Sie schon die medizinischen Fachbegriffe benutzen, bitte.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Okay. Gut.
Dann kommen wir mal zum Abschluss.
Ja, die Anamnestischangaben wie...
...linkseitige Kopfschmerzen...
...und auch andere Seiten...
...einen Nasenpolyp, Geschichte vor Geschichte...
...und eine Schwellung des Gesichtes.
Eine Schwellung der linken Gesichtshälfte?
Ja, linken Gesichtshälfte.
Linkseitige, ja, linken Gesichtshälfte.
Linkseitige, ja.
Und einen Nasenpolyp vor Geschichte.
Und keine Fieber.
Ja.
Ja, es ist Möglichkeit...
...deuten am besten eine...
...einseitige...
...wo war das?
Es ist nicht die beste Möglichkeit.
Es ist keine beste Möglichkeit.
Also keine Luft.
Also ich wiederhole, die Patientin ergibt als Hauptsymptome...
...oder die wichtigsten Symptome gibt sie an.
Druck auf der Wange, Druck auf der linken Gesichtshälfte.
Sie bekommt über die linke Nase oder über das linke Nasenloch...
...keine und hat starke Kopfschmerzen.
Woran ist das erste an das Sie denken?
Ja, Nasenpolyp.
Vergrößerte oder nicht, ich denke eine Gehirntümer.
Also das heißt sie hat ja erst Symptome seit ca. 3 Wochen.
Und das ist jetzt seit einer Woche schlimmer geworden.
Und da denken Sie, diese Nasenpolypen hat sie schon seit vielen Jahren...
Nein, nein, nicht Polypen.
Ich meine Gehirntümer.
Ah, ok. Also das heißt Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose...
...oder Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose ist ein Gehirntumor.
Ja, auf eine Gehirntümer hin als Differentialdiagnose...
Ihre Differentialdiagnose?
Sie sagen...
Migräne.
Also Sie sagen Gehirntumor und dann ist die Differentialdiagnose Migräne.
Jawohl, was noch?
Eine druckende Kopfschmerz, nicht druckende.
Andere Kopfschmerzen, andere Cephalgie-Typen.
Andere Cephalgie, Migräne, Cephalgie, was noch?
Ja.
Und...
Ok, wir machen mal hier einen Punkt.
Haben wir hier Heil-O-Ärzte unter uns?
Was? Nein.
Heil-O-Arzt, wer ist hier Heil-O-Arzt?
Oder ein Internist, ein Allgemeinmediziner?
Also, dann machen wir mal hier eine kleine Testphase.
Wir haben jetzt die Symptome.
Es gibt ein Sprichwort, das heißt was viel ist, ist viel, was wenig ist, ist wenig.
Also, ich würde jetzt nicht gleich als erstes an einen Hirntumor denken.
Ja, ok.
Normalerweise denke ich auch, aber es gibt keine Lösung für mich.
Das wäre für mich eher eine Differentialdiagnose.
Ich denke, die erste Verdachtstdiagnose, woran ich denken würde,
wäre eher an eine Sinusitis Maxillares.
Ja, aber es gibt keine Fieber und keine...
Ok, das müssen wir jetzt feststellen.
Nicht jede Sinusitis hat gleich Fieber.
Sie bekommt aber keine Luft, hat Schmerzen, hat Druck.
Ja.
Das geht seit drei Wochen.
Also das erste ist eher, denke ich, würde ich jetzt sagen, eine Sinusitis.
Ja, weil die Nase nicht richtig abläuft.
Das zweite, das wird gefördert wahrscheinlich durch diese vergrößerten Nasenpolypen,
was sie hat.
Und was auch anscheinend schon mal operiert werden sollte.
Aber es ist nicht operiert.
Das zweite, sie denken an einen Hirntumor.
Was für eine Art von Tumor soll das sein?
Sie hat ja nur neurologische, oder sie hat keine neurologischen Symptome.
Außer, was hat sie für eine neurologische Symptome?
Hat sie angegeben, sie sieht ein bisschen schlecht, hat sie gesagt.
Sie hat, wenn es ein Hirntumor ist, das heißt ein zentraler Tumor,
dann hat man meistens neurologische Ausfälle wie bei einem Plaganfall.
Das heißt keine Hemiparesie, keine Hemiplegie, keine Kribbelparästhesien,
keine Muskelschwäche, keine Seh-Ausfälle oder muskuläre Ausfälle.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist eher gering.
Aber man muss daran denken.
Gut, haben vielleicht die Kollegen noch andere Differentialdiagnosen
oder Vorschläge oder Kritiken, das wird ihm jetzt interessieren.
Ist das möglich, eine paranasale Tumore?
Paranasaltumoren? Okay, also Sie denken an Tumore im Nasennebenhöhlenbereich?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Sie müssen ein bisschen von der Ferne sprechen.
Nein, ich setze nur auf Retinoblaston.
Retinoblaston, das ist für 4 und 60 Jahre ein bisschen schwer.
Okay, was mir jetzt einfällt ist, was ich auch schon mal hatte,
eine Patientin, wie heißt dieser Kanal vom Auge in die Nase?
Tränennkanal?
Einfach eine Tränennkanalentzündung oder diese Tränensack,
das entzündet, dass dieser Kanal sich vereitert
und das kann auch mal zu einer Schwellung, Schmerzen
und eine Vereiterung führen.
Also eine Tränensackentzündung durch entweder Verengung des Kanals.
Herr Augnaz, wir haben doch einen Augnaz gehabt, wo ist der Augnaz?
Herr Ayrter, wie nennt man diese Entzündung am Auge?
Ja, das ist aber...
Orbital cellulitis vielleicht.
Komplizierte Nebennasenentzündung oder maxillare sinusitis
führt manchmal retroorbital Eileitung oder Abscess.
Abscess, wie heißt dieser Kanal zwischen Auge und Nase?
Auf Lateinisch nasolacrimal.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Nasolacrimalkanal, ok.
Wenn der sich vereitert, dann muss man das öffnen oder operieren
oder durchstechen und so weiter.
Gut.
Wenn jetzt keine Kritiker oder andere Differenzialdiagnosen
von den Kodikum, wir wiederholen mal.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, Verdachtsdiagnose ist erst mal
Sinusitis maxillaris oder eine chronische Sinusitis
oder Entzündung des Tränennkanals, eine Vereiterung.
Zweitens eine Entzündung der Gesichtshaut,
eine cellulitis oder ein Eryzipel oder ein Hautinfekt.
Dann haben Sie gesagt, ein Tumor im nasoorbital Bereich,
natürlich ein zentraler Tumor.
Sie haben gesagt, eine Migraine oder eine andere Sorte von Kopfschmerzen.
Und Sie nehmen Blut ab, machen weitere bildgebende Untersuchungen,
wie zum Beispiel eine Computertumografie oder ein Röntgen.
Man kann Ultraschall der Nasen nehmen, Höhlen machen,
das auch schon mal sehen.
Und dann entscheiden Sie, je nachdem, was da rauskommt,
ob Sie eine Antibiose brauchen oder vielleicht sogar operativ angegangen werden müssen.
Jetzt zu Ihnen, Herr Doktor, meine Kritik an Sie.
Sie machen sehr viele Leichtsinnsfehler.
Sie wissen das, Sie kennen die Grammatik,
Sie kennen die Begriffe, aber Sie sind nicht konzentriert.
Sie vergessen die Worte, Sie verwechseln die Grammatik,
Sie achten nicht auf Singular, Plural und die Worte.
Das kann zu einem Problem bei der Prüfung werden.
Und da müssen Sie ein bisschen aufpassen, denke ich.
Und machen Sie nicht zu lange Sätze.
Jetzt die erste Vorstellung, Patient kam mit,
erdrückende, lange, dann, dann, dann, Schmerz.
Sagen Sie lieber kurze Sätze.
Patient kommt mit Schmerzen am Gesicht zum Beispiel oder unterhalb vom Auge,
bekommt keine Luft durch die Nase,
hat Schmerzen und es geht seit drei Wochen schon.
Sie hat keine Besserung trotz Schmerzmedikamente, Nasenspray usw.
Sie hat bisher keine Antibiotika, sie hat kein Fieber.
Also lieber, wenn Sie sich unsicher sind, kurze Sätze.
Oder nur zwei, drei Worte, aber nicht fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Worte hintereinander.
Sie haben dann vergessen, was Sie sagen wollten.
Den Eindruck habe ich gehabt, Patientin kommt mit.
Warum ist sie jetzt eigentlich da, was habe ich noch gesagt oder nicht?
Entweder Sie sind sicher und sagen das oder lieber dann kurze Sätze.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, heute Abend sind Sie ein bisschen durcheinander,
Sie sind ganz konzentriert, müde oder ist es die Aufregung, Nervosität?
Nein, ich habe nicht richtig diagnosiert gemacht.
Was sind Sie noch mal für einen Facharzt?
Genetische.
Genetische Arzt, okay.
Also Sie sind genetisch, d.h. Sie haben wenig klinische Erfahrung.
Nein, ich habe viele klinische Erfahrungen, aber nicht Entzündung oder nicht Faktor oder nicht ähnliche Dinge.
Meine Fachzeiten sind so verschieden.
Okay. Gut, also Ihre Deutschkenntnisse sind gut.
Sie kennen auch die Grammatik, aber ich hoffe, Sie können sich gut konzentrieren während der Prüfung.
Ja, inschallah.
Machen nicht so viele Fehler, inschallah.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Jetzt sind noch Fragen von anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Heute kam wenig Kritik, wenig Einwand.
Gab es fehlende Fragen bei der Anamnese, die Arzt fragen muss?
Nein, ich glaube die Fragen waren direkt.
Es war nach der Dauer der Schmerzen, wie lange es geht, nach der Intensität, ob sie Fieber hat, was sie nicht will.
Das war schon ganz okay.
Auch die Familienanamnese und so weiter war ganz gut.
Die ganze Vorgeschichte.
Und ich denke, das war schon ganz korrekt.